[MUSIC PLAYING, FLUTTERING PAPER
SOUND]
[DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Ladies and
gentlemen, please welcome,
Vice President EMEA Google
Cloud, Sebastien Marotte.
[DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYING]
SEBASTIEN MAROTTE: Morning!
[APPLAUSE]
Morning, everyone.
Welcome.
Welcome to Google
Next, Amsterdam, 2017.
We are super excited, very
thrilled to have all of you
here.
We have put a lot of
energy, a lot of passion
to organize this day.
It's really a very
important day,
so welcome to this nice,
little, charming Dutch house.
It's kind of a cool place.
We've put, also, a lot of
folks to renovate this place
and to build this place for you.
I was told that this used to
be a ship manufacturing, so
a factory, which
was built in 1920.
And from 1920 to 1924, they have
doubled the production of ship
here.
So they move from
downtown to this place.
So it's a really cool place.
So welcome.
Super excited to host this day.
It's a great event for us.
It's a bit of world
tour, we have done,
during the past few weeks.
We started in San Francisco.
I think it was in
something like April, May.
And at that time, we have
made more than 100 product,
customer, and partner
announcements.
So a lot of great things
that we've been announcing.
And today is going to
be, also, very cool,
because we're
probably going to make
additional few announcements.
So it's a great opportunity.
I think most of the
audience, today,
is coming from a
development community.
So it's a great
opportunity for us
to connect our engineers
with the developer community.
But today is going to be a
really great opportunity, also,
to hear from our customers,
how they are turning
these amazing new technologies
into very innovative ideas that
are really changing the way
they run their business.
So a lot of great
stuff, customer stories,
a lot of product
demonstration, and a lot
of discussions around
what is really important
to consider when you're starting
this journey into the cloud.
Because this is
definitely a journey.
So I want to spend a few
minutes on a few things.
First of all, for a lot of
you, it's a bit of a discovery.
The question mark is, what is
this Google Cloud business?
For others, you're
going to deep-dive
into some part of the story and
some part of the technology.
So why don't we start, first
of all, about Google Cloud?
If you think about Google
Cloud, Google Cloud
is pretty much the
extension of everything
we have been doing at Google
since we created the company.
I was not there in 1998.
I had an immense
privilege, actually,
to start this
business in Europe,
the Google Cloud business,
six, seven years ago.
But when you think about 1998,
when Larry and Sergey created
the company, they had
a vision and a mission,
which still is very
much in play today.
It's really to organize
the world information
and to make it accessible and
useful for everyone on Earth.
And think about the
enterprise space.
We are running, we are
part of great companies,
whether you are digital
natives or you're
an enterprise company.
And it's exactly the same.
Think about it.
It's really about the data.
We are just managing,
swimming into the data,
whether it's customer data
or it's industrial data.
And what we really
care at Google
is really to turn this data
into a comprehensive business
models, into innovation,
so that you can not only
change the way you
run your business,
but, more importantly, really
build a competitive advantage
to build what's next.
And this is why this
event is called Next.
We really care
about what is going
to be next, which
products, services
you are going to create
for your customers,
and, again, to be
more competitive.
And at the end of the
day, actually, at Google,
we realized that it was
just pretty much what
we were doing, as I said, since
the beginning of our story.
But this is the way we
have built our own company.
And this is the way we
have grown our company.
If you think about
it, Google Cloud
is really enterprise business.
And it's really built on three
or four very important pillars.
One is the data center
and the infrastructure
we have been building.
The other one is
the amazing network
that we have built,
around the globe,
actually, to be able
to transfer this data
and to process this data.
The other one is
mobility if you had
to think about a third pillar.
And the last one is the one
we are talking about pretty
much everywhere, which
is machine learning
and artificial
intelligence, which
is being baked in everything
we are doing right now.
So think about the platform.
At the end of the
day, our mission
is really to deliver a highly
scalable, open, and secure
platform, to build your
business, if you're
digital natives,
or to build what's
next if you are an
enterprise company.
And we've got a few layers.
And this is very
important, actually,
because this is
really how we're going
to run this day, together.
The first one, which is super
important is infrastructure.
I mean nothing would
have been happen
without the infrastructure
that we have been building
at Google, all
these data centers
that we have been building,
that we are expanding across all
the different geographies.
And a good thing, if you
think about the Netherlands
and the Benelux, we have one
of the largest infrastructure
and data center,
around the world,
in this region, which
is really great.
This is infrastructure
that we have inherited.
And this infrastructure
that is hosting--
probably you've
heard about that--
more than seven services
that are being used
by more than a billion users.
And that's super important.
I mean there is no
way you're going
to be able to manage,
in your enterprise,
the volume of data that
is, right now, floating
into your company without
the super capacity, actually,
to host this data.
So this is also--
and that, you probably
don't know, actually--
if you think about our
Google Cloud customer,
I mean they are, themselves,
servicing more than a billion
users within their community.
This is really
the infrastructure
that is hosting our amazing
products around data analytics
and around machine learning.
So this is important.
The other thing which
is very important
is what we are providing
to the developer community.
And a lot of things are going
to be demonstrated today.
Whether its all the smarter
APIs that you can find,
the translation API, the
Video APIs, the Vision API,
all these sets of APIs
run natural language.
They are, here, totally
open and usable.
Or these amazing,
actually, products
around [INAUDIBLE] management
or Kubernetes and, again,
all the smart APIs.
So we are really investing for
the developer community, which
is extremely important,
actually, to build,
again, your next applications.
The other thing that
we care a lot about--
and I know that we've
got a lot of companies
in the room that are using these
products-- is productivity.
So we not only want to
deliver the right technology
to build your next application,
but we really want, actually,
to help you change the way you
are working within your company
by better engaging
your employees
through some live
collaboration processes.
I had a chance to, again,
join this company six,
seven years ago.
And I don't remember
the last time I really
attached a file in an email.
This is totally over.
I mean it's really about
live collaboration.
It's about engaging
people, together.
And we will have
a specific session
on that, which is totally
changing, actually, the way
people are working and really
implementing a new culture
within your company.
The other thing we
really care a lot about,
and that you probably heard,
and you will hear more and more,
is all about our
mobile strategy.
And whether it's
Android, of course,
which is by far the most
used operating system
in the environment, in
the mobile environment--
now we're getting into
the enterprise space--
or the Chrome OS,
which is probably
the more secure and
sharable and easy
operating system to access
all of this information.
There are a lot of
studies, right now,
stating that, by 2018, 25%
of the Fortune 500 companies
will start using Chrome
OS, as an operating system,
to securely work
into their company
and to their environments.
So this is the platform,
this open platform
that we are, right now,
delivering to the marketplace.
So what happens in 2017?
I mean we all know that the
cloud is the thing that we
need to embrace and to adopt.
We all know that every single
business, every single industry
is being disrupted.
I have, again, the privilege
to meet a lot of executives.
I used to live in
America, where we
were hosting a lot of executive
in our existing briefing
centers.
And every single
executive, coming
from any kind of
industries, are telling us
that their industry
is being disrupted.
And they really want
to partner with us
to figure out how
they can be leading
this next generation and their
business within their industry.
So at the same time, the market
is moving extremely fast,
we are also investing
a lot in this business.
And to be very candid,
actually, two, three,
four years ago, we were being
questioned about how serious
Google was with this business.
And for the past
24 to 36 months--
and I hope you've
seen that, actually,
and we would like to
get your feedback, also.
It's really important
to get that today--
we have been investing in
making this company really
an enterprise-ready company,
by our engineers, actually,
releasing 500 releases
during the next few years,
or by launching these
new great products--
and we have dedicated
sessions to discover products,
like a cloud machine
learning or like Spanner--
but also by implementing
some technical resources
and connecting, again, our
engineers to our company.
So this is super important.
There is another thing which
is extremely important.
And you will have
some sessions today.
Its compliance,
policy, and security.
At the same time,
everybody is moving
to the cloud, what we
are seeing is the highly
regulated industries
and companies are
going to the cloud.
And especially in Europe
and in this country,
in particular, it is
super important, actually,
to spend a lot of time, efforts
on compliance and security.
The other thing that we are
investing a lot of time,
at Google Cloud, is to
making sure that not only
we can provide the best tools
and processes around machine
learning, which I think is
definitely where we are leading
the game, or analytics or
big data and big query,
but its really about
lifting and shifting
your on-premise
workloads into the cloud.
And we have dedicated
teams, actually,
to help you migrating this.
So we are here to solve business
issues, whichever, actually,
your are belonging to.
So whether you're a
hospital or a bank,
or whether you are
running a store
or you are building a video
game or you're running a media
company or you're making energy,
I think we are seeing a lot,
a lot of companies coming to
us and adopting our business.
So for instance, we've got
a lot of digital natives,
historically,
companies in Europe
very close to my heart,
actually, like Spotify
or very famous companies
like eBay or Snapchat.
They literally built
Snapchat, built its business
on Google Cloud.
Companies like Spotify,
that I mentioned,
moved all their workloads
into Google Cloud,
actually, to go to the
next step and really
provide a much better
business experience
and build, actually, competitive
advantage to be leading,
actually, the market
they're operating into.
But you're seeing,
on these styles,
a lot of very
traditional companies.
And this is where it's
fascinating, actually,
to be part of their journey,
on how we can really
coach these companies to move,
successfully, to the cloud
and step by step.
I think one of the
largest company
we are starting
the journey with--
and probably you had
a chance to listen
to Darryl West, the global CIO,
when he was in San Francisco--
is HSBC.
Think about HSBC.
It's probably the oldest
bank in the world.
They have been in the
business for 150 years.
And it's probably one of the
most conservative companies
in the world, I mean, in
the most regulated industry,
of course, which is
the banking industry.
And it's fascinating to
see that a company that
has been created 150
years ago, of course,
has generated a
lot, a lot of data.
Actually, it's funny, because
it took them 130 years
to start measuring their
data into terabytes.
And for the past 20
years, actually, they
have generated 15 petabytes.
And now, they are
thinking about how
they are going to handle an
additional 5 petabytes just
for the next 12 months.
This is what we
are talking about.
It's really a total explosion.
So if you think
about HSBC, again,
which is a very
traditional company,
they did everything right
for the past 20 years.
They started with
relational database.
And then they
reached the limits.
And they moved
progressively, actually,
to the traditional
data warehousing that
was variable 15, 20 years ago.
And they found that
warehouses started
to be really expensive
and difficult to manage.
So what have they done?
They moved to this
big data, actually,
technologies with Hadoop.
And they found it
extremely challenging,
because, suddenly,
they had, actually,
to learn about
these technologies.
They had to learn how to feed,
actually, this technology.
They had to build
infrastructure.
They had to maintain
And it was extremely
challenging.
So what they've
done, actually, they
started to figure out
that this is a data game.
And they didn't want,
actually, to turn their company
into a competitor of Google
or any of our competitors,
actually.
They just wanted to
run their business.
So they have decided
to select Google
to start this analytical
journey, this cloud journey.
So they are moving
the bank to the cloud.
And they are moving the bank
to the cloud with Google.
So it's, again, a journey
we are just starting.
But it's really fascinating.
And we are seeing more and
more of these cases right now.
So I'd like to
end on two things.
Number one, I really want to
thank all the partners that
are in the room.
You have an amazing exhibition.
It's extremely important for us.
If you want to be an
enterprise-ready organization,
which we are, you
need, actually,
to create this
partner ecosystem.
So it's very close to our heart.
I mean it's important to onboard
some technological partners,
but also some resellers,
then also some global system
integrators that are
going to help you, again,
migrating your workloads
and also building what's
next in your organization.
So spend some time
with these guys.
They have invested
in this event.
And they are able,
actually, to tell you
more about the value they can
bring to your organization.
At the end of the day, again,
what I said, it's a journey.
And very honestly and candidly,
I mean, it's really about you.
And the kind of discussions we
are having with our customers,
I mean, are very interesting.
Because this is so new.
This is so new for everyone.
How many times, actually,
we are sitting down
with our customers, and
they are just asking us,
how should I get started?
How do How do I do it?
Really, what do
I need, actually?
Who should I recruit?
How can I find the talents?
What am I going to do with
my IT current organization?
How can I train these people?
How much is it going to cost me?
Am I going to be, again, locked
into a kind of partnership
or so-called partnership
with an IT company?
Do I have to rewrite my code?
I mean all of these questions
are really the questions
that we are trying
to help you answer.
And this is something that Diane
Greene decided, very quickly,
when she came on
board two years ago.
She's our CEO.
She was the founder of VMware.
I mean, Diane said, we have
probably the best technology
we can find, right
now, in the market.
But stop chest-beating here.
It's not only about technology.
It's about the ability to build
an enterprise organization
and connect our technical people
to making sure that we can help
you building these projects.
So you'll see a lot
of Google Earth.
We call that Google Earth.
We have Google Earth.
And in the room, you might
see some, what we call,
customer success
engineer, that will
help you piloting and
prototyping your application.
You're going to see
a lot of engineers,
also, as I said, earlier
on, that will really
help you to drive the right
technical conversations.
You will see some
dedicated architects
that are organized by industry.
We call them the
Office of the CTU.
It's like we have tens of
CTU in the organization.
And they are here, again,
to sit down with you.
And I'm so proud
and happy, actually,
to have a lot of them
here, today, in the room.
So connect with these CTU.
And also, professional services
organization, again, that
will help you and
help our partners
to implement and to
migrate your application.
So this is what it is about.
We are super excited to
spend the day together.
We have a lot to share with
you, a lot of product models
and customer stories.
And without waiting, I'm
going to pass it over
to Julien Blanchez, who is
going to tell us about security,
privacy, and compliance.
Thank you.
Welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
[DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYING]
JULIEN BLANCHEZ:
Thank you, Sebastien.
I hope the audience will
cope with another 15
minutes of French accent.
Let's see if you can
spot, through the day,
how many accents we have
and where we come from,
each and every one of us.
My name is Julien Blanchez.
I've been working nine years
with Google, the last four
years engaged with this
engineering, security,
and compliance
teams in California.
I recently relocated
back to Brussels.
And my role, now, is to
engage with regulators
and large prospects,
large customers to help
answer the detailed
questions and facilitate
the communication between
the European market
and these engineering teams.
So today, millions
of companies are
considering to move all or some
of their workload to the cloud.
And they have several
reasons to do that.
One of the reasons
that you might not
have expected to be so
prominent and to actually
be the first one a cloud
provider talks about
is security.
And yet, it is a widely
accepted fact, today,
that large cloud platforms
offer a significant capability
to improve your security stance.
And there are a
number of reasons
for that that I want to go
over in the next few minutes.
When you want to assess the
capability of a security
system, there is a
well-known framework
that recommends to look at
the capability to anticipate,
the capability to defend,
and the capability to react.
When it comes to anticipation,
large cloud platforms,
like Google, have a
significant advantage.
As Sebastien was saying, Google
is operating eight products
with more than a billion users.
Actually Google Photo just
passed the billion user
mark a couple of weeks ago.
So this would add
one to this list.
So you can imagine the
amount of information,
the amount of
exposure, the amount
of testing we get
every single day
to know what is
happening on the cloud.
And I just want to highlight
one of these platforms.
Google Android, today,
is two billion devices.
And Google Android does a
service called SafetyNet,
that you can Google if you want.
And SafetyNet polls, every
single day, 400 million
Android devices to gather
the security information,
from the devices,
and allows our teams
to build a close to realtime
cartography of the threat
landscape.
So this gives you an idea
of the amount of information
and knowledge you
can benefit from when
you operate on these platforms.
Going on to defense,
our infrastructure teams
had the great
luxury, 18 years ago,
when they started to
build these platforms.
They could start
from a blank slate.
They did not have to
cope with generations
of legacy technology that
is creating the complexity
that, in one word, really
summarizes the security
challenge today.
It is not to say that Google
is not complex, right?
Google has 2 billion lines
of codes, 20,000 to 30,000
engineers, interacting
daily, onto 2 billion lines
of code, 40,000 to 50,000 change
requests per day on the code.
So this complexity is
mastered by automation,
intelligent
automation, not to use
the buzzword of machine learning
and artificial intelligence
here.
But these systems have allowed
to tackle, successfully,
great security challenges,
like spam, for example,
and will allow to tackle
some of the big problems,
like authentication.
And I will be elaborating on
this more, this afternoon,
in the security breakout.
So when regulators, today,
are talking about security
by design--
this is becoming a very
important criteria--
Google has embedded
security into the system,
but, also,
intelligent mechanisms
that learn to adapt
to the evolving nature
of these threats.
Next, I want to talk
about the level of control
that Google has managed to
keep over the entire technology
stack.
Because of the size we
operate at, from the hardware,
to the operating system, all the
way up to the user interface,
Google has kept a very
high level of homogeneity,
has developed and deployed
its own technology,
and kept this level
of homogeneity
across the technology stack.
This level of
homogeneity is what
allows us to identify threats
or incidents relatively faster
and react relatively
faster, because we have
less different
solutions to bring
and are less dependent
on external suppliers.
Now, in this time,
where notification reach
and the speed at which
you can react and notify
your data privacy authorities,
these kind of capabilities
are going to be critical.
And this is the kind of
strength that you really
want to have on your side.
Then we should all be
aware of the importance
of a global infrastructure
in this security game.
Today, Google is 15
data centers located
across the world, 4 of them
in Europe, Finland, Ireland,
Belgium, the Netherlands.
Two more coming before the
end of the year or very soon.
But most importantly,
these data centers
are connected by our
own proprietary fiber.
And this network
infrastructure allows us also
to deliver you very low latency
but, most importantly, when
it comes to security,
be much more in control
of our own destiny when it
comes to transport data from one
continent to the other.
More importantly, this kind
of global infrastructure
allows us to aim to deliver
the same level of security
for everybody.
You are not going to receive
more security, if you're
in Germany, then if you're
in China or in Pakistan,
for that matter, or in the US.
So this is the capability
of these large platforms.
And, really, the mission of
the Google Security team's
to deliver the same level
of security to everybody.
Now these security discussions
can go on for days,
with large prospects,
weeks, sometimes,
if we really dig into the detail
and answer all the questions.
They all end up to
the same conclusions.
Large cloud platforms offer
a significant improvement
over what most companies
can deliver today.
But they all leave our
prospect with the same feeling
that you probably have at
this moment when you realize
that, to benefit
from that security,
you need to load your data onto
a third party infrastructure.
And this requires
a leap of faith.
This requires a level of
confidence that we cannot force
onto you.
All that we can do is
be more transparent,
share more information, tell
you where our data centers are
located, tell you
who are sub-processes
are, show you the dashboards,
public, live, of availability
of our systems, to allow you
to build that confidence,
to come to sign the contract.
When you sign the
contract, this is
when you really gain
legal control over
how your data will be managed.
And you will be
looking for clauses,
like scope of processing, the
commitment that Google will not
use your data for
any other purpose
than deliver you the
service that you paid for,
the commitment on
intellectual property,
portability, the contractual
commitment that you
can leave the infrastructure
at any given moment.
How we will react to
a third party request
to access your data,
international jurisdiction
will be also added
to these clauses.
The commitment that we
will keep the security
certifications,
that we have now,
during the entire duration
of the agreement with you.
And finally, the
capability that you
have to verify
that we do what we
say through audits
and the capability
to audit our systems.
Now, most of you and
most of your stakeholders
that you will have to go out
and convince, will be wondering,
how this can work within the
legal framework in Europe?
And, notably, with the
arrival of the GDPR,
this new regulation that
is going to increase,
dramatically, the power
of the data privacy
authorities to make
sure that we all
do what we should do when
it comes to handling data.
The deadline is coming close.
And that is why
we have announced,
several weeks ago, already,
our firm commitment
for Google Cloud, Google
Cloud platform and G Suite
will comply with the
expectations of the GDPR.
And you will be receiving, in
the coming weeks and month,
new legal terms
that really confirm
that you have these
commitments that
will allow you to
remain compliant
with your European regulation.
The GDPR is very specific
on one topic, which is
international data transfers.
And Article 46 of
the GDPR is what
you want to Google if you
want to have the legal text.
I encourage you to do that.
It is actually, for once,
a very easy, simple clause,
article to read.
Article 46 specifies,
very clearly,
that a data controller,
which is you,
or a data processor,
which is us,
may only export European
data outside of Europe
if adequate safety
measures are in place.
And that is why,
back in January,
we had our adequate
safety measures,
as described in our standard
contractual clauses,
added to our contract.
We had them verified
and approved
by the European institutions.
That clearly means
that, under the GDPR,
you will not be required
to keep data only in Europe
when you are using a
Google Cloud Platform.
You may do so.
You may not do so.
You may use the
platform, as you wish,
if you have these
contract clauses.
Now, very clearly, when
you engage into the cloud,
you understand that there
is a significant portion
of the compliance
and security demands
of the regulators that are
going to be managed by Google.
And this portion will vary
depending if you implement
software-as-a-service,
platform-as-a-service,
infrastructure-as-a-service.
But even in the
green area, where
regulators and your
customers will be expecting
you to raise your
game and deliver it
to the new level of expectations
of the European regulator,
Google technology can help
you achieve these goals.
And I just want to tease you
with a couple of the building
blocks that are available.
And we can discuss,
further, during the day.
The strong
authentication ranks very
high on the list of regulators,
today, and the list of hackers,
today, when it comes to
assessing your capability
to defend.
Rolling out these
security keys, that
are a 2-step authentication
factor, hardware token,
that we have rolled out at
Google, several years ago,
can significantly
improve your capability.
Enforcing their usage
is also a good idea,
just talking about
authentication.
Another big topic
is anonymization,
the regulator requires you
now to anonymize and encrypt
the data.
When using Google
Cloud technology,
your data is
encrypted by default.
This is a significant
differentiator
versus other platforms.
We will manage the
encryption for you.
If you decide, you may
manage your own keys,
you may manage the
keys, yourself.
Or you may bring your
own encryption keys
to remain completely in
control of your data.
Finally, in the spirit of
[INAUDIBLE] Wood and Mark
[INAUDIBLE],, I want
to introduce Peter,
who will demonstrate the
capability of the Data Loss
Prevention API, which will
allow you to scan your own data,
to identify person
information or sensitive data,
sometimes even possibly in
realtime in your systems.
And that can greatly help you in
your journey towards the GDPR.
Peter?
PETER BAVINCK:
Thank you, Julien.
I want to show you a short demo
of an enterprise application
that can be used in a
customer service organization.
So this is a chat application.
And in this scenario, we've
been chatting with Angela,
solving her issue.
Now, typically, in
such a chat, you
would ask for some
personal information
to make sure you look
up her history, see
if she had other issues
before, and that sort of stuff.
So we asked for her name
and her contact number.
And she did provide that.
But in the meantime, she
gave us so much more.
She gave her insurance number.
And she even uploaded a
picture of her passport.
Now, that's probably not
the smartest thing to do,
but it gives us
a problem, right?
Because if we want to store
the content of this chat, which
is commonly done,
we have a problem,
because it contains personal,
identifiable information.
So we can't use it for auditing.
We can't use it for analysis.
We can't use it for training
purposes and so forth.
So what the DLP API provides,
it provides a mechanism
to take the content of this
chat, run it through the API,
and provide a redacted
version of this content, where
all that personal
information has been removed.
So let me respond to Angela,
thanking her and end the chat.
So now, all the content is
running through the API.
And what you will notice here
is that all the information that
is personal has been redacted.
We see that her
name was taken out.
We see that her phone number has
been removed, insurance number.
We even went into the
picture to take out her face
and remove any sensitive content
from the picture, as well.
And to show you
that this is live,
I have a small document
scanner set up here.
I have a sample of
a Dutch passport.
Its fake, so you don't
need to take pictures.
I can put it under the scanner,
click on the Capture Image,
and it will run through the API,
and it will correctly identify
the [NON-ENGLISH] number.
And it will take out the face.
So that's an example of how
you can apply the Data Loss
Prevention API in
your organization,
in an enterprise application.
Back to you, Julien.
JULIEN BLANCHEZ: Thank you,
Peter, very impressive.
[APPLAUSE]
PETER BAVINCK: Thank you.
JULIEN BLANCHEZ: When you
speak to your risk managers
in your organization,
and you hear
how worried they are about
every single one of us
organizing the birthday
parties of our children
through our corporate
emails and capturing,
thereby, the identity of
all these children, of all
their parents, and then having
the regulator come in two years
and asking, why you did
you keep that information?
This is the kind
of technology that
will help your risk managers.
So I do not want to leave you
without a parting thought.
At the end of these
discussions, you
are faced with
executives that have
to decide whether they go to
the cloud or not go to cloud,
a very confusing decision.
And I, since a few
weeks, recommend now
to divide the decision process
into four different steps.
The first is to make a purely
technical risk assessment.
Where is your data
going to be safer
from a purely technical
point of view?
And I'm quite confident,
very confident actually,
that this process will
lead to the direction
we talked about in
the last few minutes.
Then, engage into
a legal assessment.
What does the law
really require?
And as we've discussed
about the GDPR,
it will unify the legal
landscape in Europe.
It has very clear expectations.
The discussions, the
legal discussions
are actually getting
much easier by the month.
Then, make a
political assessment.
There are a number
of countries, today,
that are passing laws to
keep the data in country.
And you need to be sure
that your cloud provider can
cope with these demands.
These countries, you
know them, two years ago,
Russia, six months ago, China.
And our teams are paying
a lot of attention
to a couple of other
countries in the central parts
of the world, the Middle
East, at the moment,
where these decisions
could also take place.
You get the picture.
Data location laws
are very rarely
meant to improve the
privacy of the data.
Nevertheless, you need to remain
operational in these countries.
Can your cloud provider
guarantee the security
of the data while,
at the same time,
satisfying the expectations
of these regulators?
An important assessment.
Finally, the
cultural assessments,
you might be faced
with reactions
like I see a lot in
France, for example.
I'm a French company.
I want my data to
remain in France.
Or you have unions that have
expectations for the data
to remain in France.
Or your data is deemed
national treasure.
Very fine, these are
very good reasons
why you might not be able
to get the data outside.
But make sure that, when you go
through your decision process,
you clearly make a
distinction between these four
different levels and
prioritize them accordingly
in your decision.
This is the last thing I want
to say before introducing you
to Tino, who will tell you
more about machine learning
and our big data capabilities.
Tino, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYING]
TINO TERSHKO: Thank you, Julien.
No French accent, I'm sorry.
Well, I am absolutely
ecstatic to be here.
I absolutely love Amsterdam.
The energy, the sophistication,
the technical talent
here is just astonishing.
And on a personal
level, Amsterdam
is one of my favorite
places in the whole world.
It's just such a tremendous
place to be here.
And I'm just beyond
ecstatic here.
So Julien did a
fantastic job telling you
how Google can protect your
organization from a security
point of view.
I'd like to talk about a little
bit of a different angle,
and that's basically data.
How can an organization
embrace data?
Because the reality
of today's world,
today's environment is that you
must be a data company in order
to succeed.
So you must have an
innovation partner
that can help you
manage your data
and get the most
value out of the data,
provide analytics, help you
understand your customers,
and help interact with the
world through machine learning
and artificial intelligence.
But the reality of today's
technical environment,
again, is that infrastructure
is very complex.
Your engineers are
tasked with a number
of day-to-day engagements.
There's a whole lot
of things that you
must do, every
single day, in order
to just keep the lights on.
And these things are
relatively low value.
You can consider them
tinkering with infrastructure.
And the one little bit
that really provides value
to organization can be very,
very small, relatively small.
So what if you could flip
that equation on its head.
So Google Cloud Platform
provides a large number
of services that are
very, very, high level,
fully managed services
that abstract away
a lot of complexity of managing
your own infrastructure
and your own services, a very,
very high level of abstraction,
a very, very high
level of automation.
That allows your
engineers to focus
on what's really important
to your organization
and try to provide
value, which accelerates
your base of innovation,
allows you to iterate,
allows you to delight
your customers,
allows you to focus
on your customers.
And I'm delighted to
present George, here,
from Philips, who is going
to talk about how Philips has
implemented Google
Cloud Platform
and solved their issues when
implementing the Philips Hue
Platform.
George?
GEORGE YIANNI: Thank you, Tino.
[APPLAUSE]
It's a great pleasure
to be here, today,
to tell you about my
product, Philips Hue,
and how we're using the Google
Cloud Platform to connect
lighting to the
internet and hopefully
change it for everyone forever.
Philips Lighting is the world's
largest lighting company.
And I'm pretty
confident when I say
that every single
person in this room
has experienced at least
one of our products,
whether it's with
regular lighting you have
in your own homes, lighting
you walked under in street
lamps on the way here,
or the lighting in one
of the thousands of monuments,
like the Rijksmuseum,
here, in Amsterdam,
that we light.
One of the key
drivers of my company
is transforming the
role of lighting
by making it more connected.
We believe that we can
leverage the fact that lighting
is everywhere,
ubiquitously around us,
to make the world easier to
personalize, easier to monitor,
easier to manage, and
easier to control.
My product, Philips
Hue, is our answer
to that in the consumer space.
It's one of the most
popular smart home products
in the world.
And what we really believe
is that we can totally
transform the role that
lighting plays in your home.
We believe that lighting can
be an alternative to having
a guard dog by making it seem
like you're at home when you're
away on vacation.
We believe that lighting
could be an alternative
to your morning cup of
coffee by leveraging
the physiological
response our body has
to different shades
of white light.
We believe that lighting
is an alternative
to painting your
home and decorating,
by being able to change the
look and feel of a space
multiple times a day, by
changing the brightness
and color of your lights.
We even believe that lighting
can be an alternative
to a surround sound
system by extending
the experience of the
screen into your room
with synchronized light scripts.
And we can do all of this
while making your home more
convenient and comfortable.
Now, we started with
Philips Hue back in 2012.
And from the very
beginning, we knew
we needed to have
a cloud backend.
We needed to be able
to keep our products
up-to-date in the field.
We needed to be able to
understand and learn,
from how people are
using the system,
to make it better over time.
We needed to give the
ability for consumers
to control their lights when
they weren't at home, so
that they could have
the lights automatically
be on when they
arrived home and be
able to check that
they hadn't left things
on when they were away.
And we also knew we wanted
to connect our lighting
to react to other
cloud services,
like if this, then that, so that
all of your lights in your home
can flash red when your
favorite sports team scores.
All of these told us we
needed a cloud platform.
But we also had some
unusual requirements.
The way we actually
serve this cloud
service towards
our customers is we
bundle it for free in
the initial purchase
price of the product.
And what that means
is we actually
have to bundle the lifetime
cost of serving that customer
into that initial purchase price
as part of the bill of material
of our product.
So it's absolutely
crucial for us,
in order to keep the product
affordable for consumers,
that the incremental cost
of serving a new home
is kept as low as possible.
And that way, we're
able to actually
make the purchase price
of the product cheaper.
We also needed to
make sure that we
could scale this product in
a very cost-effective way.
We didn't know, when we
started, if this product would
be hugely successful or
would take slower to ramp up.
And because we started
as an internal start-up,
we didn't want to
be lumbered with
a huge operational overhead
keeping this thing running.
But equally, if it did take
up very fast, which luckily it
did, we need to be able
to keep up with scaling.
Google Cloud solved this for us.
And we're constantly,
pleasantly surprised,
as the market keeps
growing faster and faster,
that we're able to keep up with
scaling in a very smooth way.
Another thing, which has
become increasingly important,
is we care about latency.
We've been trained,
the last 100 years
of having lighting in our homes,
that when you press a button
the light turns on immediately.
Why should it be any
different if you have
internet connected lighting?
So we put a lot of energy into
optimizing the total latency,
from when you do an action,
which goes via the cloud,
to the lights re-acting,
becoming even more important
with voice platforms
in our home.
We have a very broad
partnership with Google.
We use a wide variety of
different Google Cloud
products.
But we also work very closely
with the Android ecosystem
and with the smart home
products in the Google thing,
like Nest and Google Assistant.
So let's have a quick look at
what it takes to actually turn
on a light bulb in 2017.
Let's start with a
command from something
like Google Assistant.
So someone in their home,
they get out their phone,
they say, OK, Google,
turn off my lights.
What happens?
That command goes up to
the Google infrastructure,
does the voice recognition,
generates the command.
And it comes with a client
request towards our API.
The API is initially
managed by Apigee,
where we're handling
that the command is
properly authenticated
and within the quotas
of its application.
That's then passed over
towards a service that
runs in Google Container Engine,
called Client Eastwood, which
handles that request, make
sure that it's connected,
throws the right bridge, and
routes that message via a Redis
instance running
on Compute Engine,
towards another container,
which actually handles
the connection towards bridges.
The new way we're
doing this now is
with a service we call Freddie
Mercury, which actually
maintains a permanent,
open web socket
towards every single
bridge in the world.
And we do that to get
latency as low as possible.
There's always a connection
ready to take that command,
so we can turn on the lights
immediately. it arrives there,
and it's pushed
down this web socket
towards the bridge
inside the home.
The bridge takes that and
sends out a Zigbee wireless
message towards the lights in
the home, and they turn off.
And all of this happens in
less than 300 milliseconds
and happens millions
of times every day.
And that's how we turn
on a light bulb in 2017,
and how we're using Google
Cloud Platform to do it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks.
TINO TERSHKO: Thank you.
Thank you, George.
Freddy Mercury?
That was a fantastic story.
And these halls are filled with
customers and users, today,
that are leveraging Google
Cloud Platform for all kinds
of exciting use cases.
I encourage you to share
those stories with other folks
in attendance here.
And perhaps tomorrow
or next year,
you'll be on stage here with us.
So as I mentioned
before, data is
really key to success
in today's environment.
And Google has really
been at the forefront
of this kind of attitude.
As you may have
heard, Google's motto
is to organize the world's
data and essentially
provide very, very high
level value to that data.
We really mean that to heart.
Google's culture is
fanatically data driven.
All decisions are
made through data
driven argument and debate.
It can be actually a little
bit maddening, sometimes.
So this embrace of data
is really key, again.
And so in order to really
take the first steps--
let's say I convinced you--
you should probably
start by taking
care of your operational, your
transactional, your application
database layer.
And so I'm here to talk about
Cloud Spanner, which is just
an incredible technology.
It's amazing.
So traditionally, when building
an operational application
database, you had
a binary choice.
You wee probably
going to try to use
a traditional relational
database, which
has rich SQL semantics, strong
consistency transactions.
But sadly, a relational
database doesn't really scale.
You may hit some limits,
at which point, you perhaps
will choose to shard
your databases, which
increases complexity
of operations,
multiple times over.
And so the NoSQL movement was
born, where it traded away
some of the really nice
benefits of relational databases
in exchange for
horizontal scaling
and in exchange
for availability.
So you don't get
really nice SQL.
You may not get
strong consistency.
You might not get transactions.
But you'll get scale, right?
And Google
recognizes, of course,
that this is kind
of inefficient,
this binary choice.
We can do better than this.
So Cloud Spanner was born.
And at Google, Cloud
Spanner has been
in production, for the past
five or six years or so,
running hundreds
of applications,
including some of our
biggest ones like AdWords.
So what is Cloud Spanner?
It is the world's first
horizontally scalable
relational database.
Cloud Spanner provides strong
consistency of transactions,
provides rich
standard SQL dialect,
and has a very high
level of abstraction.
It's a fully managed
service, so that you're not
inundated with tasks
like setting up
infrastructure and
identifying how to shard keys
and so on and so forth.
So Spanner lets
you focus on what's
important to your business.
And again, of course, Spanner
is replicated regionally
and, potentially, even
globally, which is
a very new and novel concept.
And of course, Spanner is
battle-tested at Google
as I mentioned before.
So how does Spanner
achieve this?
It sounds too good
to be true, really.
There are two components that
I should talk about here.
The first one is TrueTime.
TrueTime is a software
and hardware server inside
of Google that allows you to
retrieve accurate timestamps
within a non-zero error bound.
TrueTime allows us to
serialize transactions
with strong levels
of confidence.
And that's really
the key to providing
strong consistency
of transactions
that are spread geographically.
The second one is a very
unique feature of Google,
that some folks before
me may have mentioned,
and that's Google's
private network.
Google manages their packets
between data centers.
It will take a packet from
data center A to data center B.
And again, very high
levels of confidence
that those packets
will make it there.
Those packets, your data
never leaves Google Network.
And we're able to
really understand
when any kind of
degradation happens there.
And so the other way
to look at it is,
you might have heard of the CAP
Theorem of distributed systems.
The CAP Theorem basically says
that there are three aspects
to distributed systems.
There's the consistency,
availability, and partitions.
And what they mean by partitions
is network partitions,
which is just a nice way of
saying that bad things happen
to networks.
And that's really what
the CAP Theorem says
is bad things
happen to networks,
so you have to choose
between c and a,
between consistency
and availability.
Google's private network
allows us to minimize the p
down to seconds a year.
In theory, we still have
the p to worry about.
But in practice, the
p is minimized so much
that it's not a concern.
So now you can have both
consistency and availability.
And that's what
Spanner gives you.
And now, I have Robert,
who has probably the best
job at Google, because he
gets to play around with tools
like Spanner every single day.
He's going to give us
a live demo of Spanner.
ROBERT SAXBY: Hi, thanks, Tino.
So all that said,
it sounds like it's
going to be a lot of work to
get Spanner up and running, no?
Well, we've tried to reduce that
to something very, very simple.
So on this first screen-- and
I'll zoom in a little bit--
we're actually going
to create an instance.
So let's call it,
Next Amsterdam.
And we're going to choose
here a number of nodes.
So these are nodes of Spanner.
And we're going to
go for 42, obviously.
And that's it.
I'm in the process now.
And I've just
created and deployed
my Spanner instance
with 42 nodes.
That's really cool.
But let's actually see a use
case and see what happens.
So we're going to
switch to our next tab.
So what's going on here?
We have an application.
It's been deployed
in three regions.
So we have Europe,
Asia, and North America.
And basically, we've got about
a billion tickets to sell.
And we have 800,000 events.
And what we're trying
to do, globally,
is sell these tickets to the
customers who want to buy them.
And obviously, we don't
want to sell the same ticket
to more than one
person, so having
a horizontal available database
is going to be really useful.
So we've deployed Spanner in
all of those three regions,
as well.
And for this demo,
we've actually
deployed Kubernetes
clusters there, as well,
to actually simulate
this interaction.
And as you can
see at the moment,
we've sold about
10 million tickets.
And we're about 600,000
tickets per minute.
So let's dive down a bit.
This is the schema that we're
using for our ticket service.
And I think there are two
things to notice here.
One, it looks like your
everyday, relational,
normalized database
schema, which is great.
Everyone can understand it.
You can have a conversation
around it, with your analyst,
with your developers.
But let's look at one
of these tables here.
So the ticket table is already
containing 1.8 billion rows.
And that's in one table.
That table isn't sharded.
That's just one table
that you can look at.
And it doesn't matter if you're
looking at it from America,
Europe, or Asia.
For all intents and
purposes, you're
looking at a local table
containing one billion rows.
So the next thing I'm going
to do is pull up a query
and actually run a
query against Spanner
while we're doing
all of this work.
So let me just go and grab
this query, which I prepared.
So we should have a
query here for Amsterdam.
Selecting that.
So I'm querying the data
while all that other stuff
is going on.
And there's one thing I want
you to notice about this query.
If I zoom in, that might
help a bit, as well.
This is a pretty normal
looking SQL query.
So something else that you get
with Spanner, normal, plain SQL
interoperability.
So the next thing
we're going to do
is add some more nodes
to our Spanner instance.
So you can imagine,
all this is going on.
One of the things that
Spanner actually offers you
is to make changes to
the schema, realtime,
which would give you that
ability to actually go and add
new features to your
system, your application.
But what about if your
application actually
needs more power?
Well, it's as simple as--
zooming in again-- editing
the instance and saying,
give me some more nodes.
And there we go.
We've just got some more nodes.
Spanner, as with all of
our Google Cloud products,
is fully integrated.
It's a fully managed service.
As you've just seen,
I'm not going in there
and configuring things and
doing all kind DevOp stuff.
But what we've also
done is make sure it's
connected with our monitoring
system, the Stackdriver.
And I just want to pay
attention here to a few graphs.
So one of the graphs,
this is the period
when we started loading this
initial data into Spanner
for this demo.
And there are few graphs
that you can have a look at.
So these are the nodes
going up and down.
But this one here, when we
started to load our data,
we were going about 200 to
300 megabytes per second.
And we actually increased
that to get some more in,
to like 600 megabytes per
second of loading data
into our Spanner instance.
And we're going to
come back to this
and look at what's happening.
We're going to zoom in
on America, a little bit,
and look at the latency there.
We're selling, there, about
200,000 tickets a minute.
So with that, I'm going
to hand it back to Tino.
That was Spanner.
[APPLAUSE]
TINO TERSHKO: Wow.
What an amazing database.
Just the fact alone, that
he was able to resize
the size of a Spanner cluster
so easily, it's transformative.
These types of things took
Google months and months
to do before Spanner.
And so you can take
advantage of this today.
Spanner went GA roughly a
month ago, almost to the date.
And again, Spanner gives
you the best of both worlds.
You get the nice SQL semantics.
You get strong transactional
layer of relational databases.
But you get the
scale characteristics
and the availability
of NoSQL databases.
So I, please, encourage you
to take a look at Spanner.
It's really exciting.
Now that we've taken care
of the application layer,
now that we have our
operational, transactional
database up and running, synced
across the entire world, let's
talk about how to get some
more value out of this data.
Because you really want to
understand your customer.
You want to delight them.
You want to have custom,
tailor-made experiences
for each individual customer.
And at the same time, you
want to be identifying
opportunities, potentially,
for future exploration
and future innovation
and future iteration.
So really, the tool that
Google uses, internally,
and Google customers
use, externally, as well,
is BigQuery.
BigQuery is a product that I
had the pleasure of working on
before coming over
onto my new team.
And BigQuery is,
essentially, a serverless,
fully managed analytics
data warehouse.
What do we mean by that?
What we mean is that you never
have to touch hardware again.
You never have to
resize your cluster.
You never have to specify
any kind of configuration,
like RAM, CPU, and so forth.
BigQuery just works.
BigQuery has two
major components
that you can think about.
The first one is a
sophisticated, exabyte-scale
storage engine that allows you
to move data into BigQuery,
in realtime, and share data
sets across your organization
or with your third parties just
the same way Google Docs allows
you to share information.
Besides storage, we have
the execution engine,
which allows you to
execute standard SQL
at the speed of
thought, gives your data
scientists, your data
engineers, your analysts
the power to see
inside of that data,
understand the
shape of the data.
So customers, of
course, prefer BigQuery
for its price and
performance characteristics.
But they're most vocal about the
operational simplicity aspect
BigQuery.
It really is a set
and forget technology.
It's really no ops.
It requires no
workloads to manage.
You just use BigQuery.
But, of course, in order to
use BigQuery properly, just
like any other
database, you need
to move data into BigQuery,
which is potentially
not the most glorious endeavor.
ETL is hard.
And it's kind of a requirement.
It's a means to an end.
So for that purpose, if you have
data sets that reside inside
of Google, if you're
an AdWords user,
if you're a DoubleClick user,
Google Analytics Premium
and YouTube, we, on your behalf,
are able to move that data,
automatically,
inside of BigQuery,
so that your analysts can use
any number of holistic tools,
like SQL or Python,
to analyze that data,
together or with data
sets that you own,
that you bring into
BigQuery, as well.
And we'll be bringing in
other data sets into BigQuery,
as well, in the future.
So our clients tell us there
are really three major ways
to use Google Cloud
Platform to derive value
for your organization.
The first one, that I
already talked about,
is this cloud native
data warehouse concept
that BigQuery holds.
And it's really transformative.
It's changing how
folks think about data
and how folks think about
analyzing data, in realtime,
in SQL.
The second one is management
on Hadoop and Spark.
It's 2017, it's been 11 years
since Hadoop first came around.
And Hadoop is still very,
very hard to work with.
It's a big headache.
It's not unusual for
clients to tell me
that it takes six to nine
months, on-premise, for them
to get more infrastructure,
to get more storage
or more compute
capacity, to increase
the size of their Hadoop
clusters-- six to nine months.
And at the same time, once you
do have capacity, sometimes,
I'm being told that a
runaway query can take down
the whole thing.
And there are tools, like YARN
ResourceManager, that allow
you to break up the resources.
But it still doesn't go far.
So Google's Hadoop and Spark
service, called Dataproc,
allows you to spin up
clusters in seconds.
To 98% of performance to
get a cluster up and running
is about 60 seconds,
which is incredible.
The third use case,
that I can talk about,
is realtime analytics.
Now, there is nothing
wrong with waiting
a day or two until you get
analysis into your business.
But there are use
cases where you
want data analyzed in realtime.
Philips Hue is a great
example of that, right?
You want analytics
on your application
as quickly as possible.
So IoT, gaming, and
clickstream stream
are three of the examples where
realtime analytics becomes
really useful.
Now, we've taken care of
the application layer.
We know what the shape
of that data looks like.
But to truly get the
most out of your data,
you can start embracing
machine learning and AI.
And this is a relatively
new concept, of course.
Actually, it's a
relatively old concept.
But because of the
advancements in computing,
it's become a practical
concept, these days.
And Google has really
attempted to democratize
the concept of AI, through
our investments in TensorFlow,
which is very popular,
open source project,
through our
acquisition of Kaggle,
which is a community of AI
and machine learning experts,
and, of course, through our
fully managed machine learning
service Cloud ML Engine.
Cloud Machine
Learning Engine allows
you to train your
custom TensorFlow
models, on your data,
using our CPUs and GPUs.
We abstract away the complexity
of running a distributed
TensorFlow cluster,
so you can just
focus on the really
difficult problem, which
is machine learning.
And once you have
the trained data set,
or once you have
your model in place,
you can take that
model, for inference,
for future use on-premise,
onto a mobile device,
or onto Google Cloud.
Of course, we all
know that AI is hard.
Machine learning
is very, very hard.
Not everybody is ready.
There's not a
whole lot of talent
that really expertly
knows machine learning.
To that extent, we
are externalizing,
and we have externalized, a
number of pre-trained machine
learning models that
power the same tools
that Google uses, today, for
example Google Photos or Google
Image Search or
Google SafeSearch,
or, actually, Google Translate.
So these same models are
being externalized for you
to use, so that
any engineer that
knows how to work with
a REST API or JavaScript
can build an application
that can talk,
that can be machine
learning-driven, AI-driven,
and can talk to the real world.
I'm going to talk about
a couple of these.
The first one is Vision API.
It's been available over
the past year or so.
And we've actually annotated
over a billion and a half
images by now.
A couple of use cases--
the first one is
real estate companies
often take images of
real estate properties
and extract metadata that
facilitates transactions.
The second one is
social media companies
are able to leverage the
Vision API to filter out
inappropriate content.
And the Vision API, just
like all of our services,
tends to iterate and innovate.
You kind of get better
and better features,
more and more features
as time goes on.
It's an intrinsic
quality of Google Cloud.
Two of the most recent features,
that Vision API has introduced,
are advanced OCR
and implementation
of Knowledge Graph metadata.
Advanced OCR, or Optical
Character Recognition,
allows you to visualize or to
translate physical documents,
like legal documents
or medical documents,
translate them into text,
extract the text away
from that.
And Knowledge Graph metadata,
essentially, what Google did
is we tied together the Vision
API with our Knowledge Graph
metadata database.
So that the same
metadata database
that powers Google
Images, for example,
you are able to use today.
So it's just enrichment
of this Vision API
with Google's internal tools.
The next one is actually
just fascinating, as well,
and you guys will
get to take a look
at what this looks like live.
The vast majority of data
that's being generated, today,
in the world is really
videos, hundreds
of terabytes every single hour.
And it's very hard to
work with videos, right?
You can't run SQL on it.
You can't really store
it in a database.
So what if you could
extract valuable information
about your videos,
video content,
in a very simple matter?
And I have Lee to
demonstrate that for us.
LEE BOONSTRA: Thank you, Tino.
Actually, I am
very excited today
to demonstrate the Video
Intelligence API, because it's
really one of my favorite Google
Cloud products that's online.
So I'll explain to
you first what it is.
It is a machine learning.
It's a pre-trained model
that we, as developers,
can use through a
REST API, so you
don't need to be
a data scientist
or build the hard stuff.
It's already there.
And once you connect
to this REST API,
machine learning can understand
the context of the video
and also detect, per screen,
per scene, what's in the scene.
And we'll label it.
And also, we'll give you back on
which timestamp that happened.
And I can show you
that in a real demo.
I have, here, a video of
YouTube searches in 2016,
where all things what
happened in the year 2016.
So I'm scrolling through it.
And you see like lots of people,
things of politics and sports.
And if you scroll down, you
can see the Video Intelligence
API detected all these
keywords, so everything
that's happening in this video.
Now imagine that
you have a company,
you no longer need
to watch a full video
to label or categorize a video.
But you can let the
computer basically do that
and also see what
time that happened.
So if we can see here,
apparently, in this scene,
there is a dog.
And here is a
construction worker.
I think that's amazing.
Let's think about
another use case.
And I think that's
probably real life.
Let's say you have a company.
And you have like petabytes of
video files on your website.
And you need to find a certain
scene to highlight that.
So let's try it that out.
Since it's officially
summer today,
I thought like maybe it's nice
to look for the word "beaches"
and see if we have videos
that contain a beach.
And now you see, these are
all videos with beaches.
As you can see, you see,
also, on which time frame
the beach area did happen.
So if I could click here, then--
let me refresh the page--
then you should see
that, indeed, also,
where the breach was
really happening.
And that is actually
pretty amazing,
because if I would
blink my eye, I probably
would have missed it.
So that is really great.
Now, I had it over back to Tino.
[APPLAUSE]
TINO TERSHKO: Wow.
Thanks, Lee.
Lee and Robert are our customer
engineers here in Amsterdam.
And I have said this before,
customer engineers at Google
probably have the coolest jobs.
They get to use
all the cool toys,
and they get to
talk to customers
and solve your real
world problems.
And they get to demo stuff.
Video Intelligence API is really
indicative of what Google Cloud
Platform is trying
to do, in general.
Video Intelligence
API is the result
of intense investments
in AI and data science
and lots of research,
inside of Google,
that makes its way into
your hands as a customer,
but also through a very, very
high level of abstraction,
so that your everyday analysts
and your everyday engineers
can leverage a simple API to
provide really valuable use
cases and to have your
applications actually interact
with the world in the
same way that humans do.
This is fascinating, right, this
new reality that we live in.
And so to kind of wrap up,
I'd like to kind of give you
a little bit of a thought.
Today, you must embrace data.
You must embrace the fact that
data drives all decision making
in the world.
And so, in order to
really propel yourself
and to innovate
further, you need
take care of all the layers of
data management, all the way
from the application database,
to the analytics database,
and then, potentially, even
to AI machine learning.
And with that, I'd
like to introduce
Bill, who is actually a
head of customer engineers,
here, for EMEA.
And Bill is going to
talk about how Google
allows you to collaborate.
BILL HIPPENMEYER: Thanks, Tino.
Appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]
So like Tino said, my
name is Bill Hippenmeyer.
And I recently have moved from
California, our Mountain View
office, to London, so that we
could build out our customer
engineering organization
across EMEA.
We're making big investments
in our go-to-market forces.
And it's Diane Greene's
belief, and my belief, as well,
that we're going to
engage best with you
when we go engineer to engineer,
when we have people that
have knowledge about products,
capabilities that we provide,
can apply those to
problems that you have,
and show you the art of the
possible of what's going next.
The problem is-- and here's
something we really have
to pause on for a minute--
that we're all trying to
drive these transformation
outcomes, new methods, new
ways to approach problems,
new markets, new customer
solutions, new ways
to interact with partners and
the ecosystem with which we
work.
That's great.
That comes from what?
That innovation is really a
result of transformative ideas
that we create and think
about in the workplace
with these same partners.
Those transformative ideas
are built on creativity.
Creativity is the
crucible which allows
us to come up with new ideas,
which lead to transformation.
But the question I have
for you, as an audience,
today, as you sit there,
is what is the catalyst
for that creative process?
What is it that gets people
to be able to come up
with new ideas
and actually think
of a different approach,
a different way,
a different method to be able to
affect an outcome that does it?
I submit to you that
that is engagement.
When two or more people get
together, they lock themselves
in a room, in a
conference place,
or they're in a Google Doc
working together, in realtime,
they're starting to create,
think, and reason together.
And what happens-- and you
all have this experience--
is you begin to synthesize new
ideas from existing components,
existing facts, and
your observations
about the world around you.
And that's what we are
doing in Google Cloud
and our collaboration suite.
We've had great success
introducing G Suite
just around 10 years ago.
I joined Google around
2007, so I'm coming up
on my 10-year anniversary.
And I began the Google journey
in the collaboration space.
And when Google brings
a new product to market,
our thinking is, how do we
impact over a billion people?
How do we solve problems that
no one else is addressing?
And how do we bring something
that is unique to the flavor
that only Google can do?
And this is what we
believe we have delivered
in the context of G Suite.
There's a problem, though.
We have a great suite
of capabilities,
from realtime collaboration,
to meetings, to Google Drive,
to all these great
products that service
that collaborative effort and
allow you to connect and create
together.
But what we've recognized
is that that's not enough.
It's not enough to
just be able to create
and to be able to work
together in realtime.
We have to take the
power of machine learning
and apply it to
everything we're doing.
Because what's happening
in the workplace today
is there are obstacles to my
creating the next big idea.
And those obstacles are, number
one, I don't have enough time.
I've got to create
space for creativity.
I've got to have a set of tools
that will optimize my day,
optimize the way I work, find
the things I need when I need
them, so that I can create
more room for creativity
and more room for collaboration.
The second thing that I have to
do is I have to lift my game.
I have to be able to work
smarter and work more
intelligently.
And I have to do so using
best practices of those that
are around me, experts
within the field,
in my sphere of
influence and outside
of my sphere of influence.
So I've got to have
intelligent solutions that
allow me to do that.
The third thing
is the tools have
to be built, fundamentally,
for teams not for individuals.
We need to have
tools that actually
get us to engage, to get
that catalyst working,
to create, to transform, and
then reap the rewards of that.
And then, finally, the fourth
point which is important
is that I've got
to have tools that
integrate with the back office,
integrate with the workflow,
and integrate with
the other components
that I use on a daily basis,
like the ERP system and CRM
system.
So what I want to do, over
the next couple of minutes,
is I want to give you a
glimpse into some of the things
that we're doing in Google
to help us solve those four
problems, that will allow us to
arrive at the transformations
we need and demand
in today's world.
Let's start a little bit
with artificial intelligence.
As you know, Google's
been working in this field
for a long, long time.
And many of have
experienced the benefit
of type-ahead, which is built
on an AI algorithm that examines
all of the different words
that people are typing in,
in different languages, to
provide useful suggestions
to be able to allow you
to find information.
That's a great example
of time savings.
When you use type-ahead,
as an example,
you're finding results faster.
You're finding more
relevant results.
And you're getting
to the information
you need quickly to get that.
But that can be integrated
into everything we do.
So let's take a look
at what we're doing
in artificial intelligence.
We're working on systems,
integrated into the G Suite
product, that will allow
you to recover lost time,
improve your team effectiveness,
and uncover big ideas.
And let's begin with Drive.
So the first innovation that
I want to talk to you about
is Drive Quick Access.
Drive Quick Access is
a mechanism by which we
are looking at your schedule.
We are looking at the
interactions you have in chat.
We're examining the
things that you're
doing, as you collaborate
with the people around you,
and then we're surfacing
the content, that you need,
at a fingertip,
when you need it.
It turns out that, if
you measure it, over 40%
of the documents that you need
are now being accessed directly
from this new capability in
Drive called Quick Access.
So when I open up Drive now,
and I look at the top bar,
yes, there's a
Search bar up there,
and, yes, it's very useful to be
able to do type-ahead searches
to find information.
But more importantly,
the documents
that I'm most likely to
need are presented to me
based on the context
and algorithms
that we're building in and
using an artificial intelligence
to surface this content.
So that's an example of
giving you more time.
It might be in
microseconds or seconds.
But if you add that
up, what that's
going to do across
the suite, is going
to allow you to have more
productive thought-time, more
productive opportunities
to engage with others.
The second innovation,
that we brought to market,
is the Explore
functionality within Sheets.
I don't know about you, but I'm
pretty good with spreadsheets,
but I'm not the guru that
can write a very, very
complex statement that uses
all of the complexities
of the spreadsheet language
to be able to search and find
things in cells.
Here's an example of a question.
What is the most
frequent garment
type, from the
point of sale data
that I've been collecting,
over the last 10 years,
analyzed by geography,
by location, by language,
by segment of the market?
When you ask that
question, how many of you
can immediately write
the formula that's
going to look at potentially
terabytes of information
and be able to pull that
information up and put it
in a graph in a
matter of seconds?
That's not an easy thing to do.
The best people that
know spreadsheets,
that work with this
data, do it well,
but the average person struggles
a bit with that formula.
So you can go into
Explore, right now,
and you can use the natural
language query processing,
and you can simply
ask that question.
What is the most
frequent garment type?
And then you can add things to
it, by geography, et cetera,
that I talked about earlier.
And we will actually
not only show
you the results of that
query, but we'll also
write the formula for you.
So if you want to
take that formula
and drop it into the cells that
apply and do the summarization,
you'll get that immediately.
And now the next person that
wants to come into that Sheet
and examine that
content, they do not
have to be able to
write the formula.
They don't even have to
know to ask the question.
The information is
available to them,
processed, and ready to go.
So being able to
raise your game,
raise your ability to
interact with the data,
move to a natural language
processing capability
is one of the outcomes that you
get from the application of AI
and machine learning into,
in this case, Sheets.
But how do we
enhance your ability
to collaborate together?
Well, there are a
number of things
that we're releasing
in the product, now,
and have recently
released to be able to get
people to be able to
engage more proactively,
engage in realtime.
We've talked about Google Drive.
And Google Drive is
going to be the next.
We predict, by the
end of this year,
that Google Drive will be
over the billion monthly
active user point.
And when we measure
an active user,
that is not a registered user.
That is someone who
is a seven-day active.
Somebody who's used the
product in the context
of the last seven days.
So finding your information
and placing your documents
in Drive, we think is good.
But that, again, is not enough.
So this year, we
announced Team Drive.
Team Drive is that creative
space where I can declaratively
create the space, I can add
the colleagues and people
that are working with me
on a particular project.
And then, now, what happens is
all the content that we create,
all the content that
we interact with,
and all the stuff
that we store belongs
to the team not the individual.
This solves a
number of problems.
The first problem
it solves is what
happens when a new team member
comes in to your existing file
structure system?
You have to go through and
do all the shares required
to be able to bring that
person into the project.
With Team Drive, we
eliminate that need.
As soon as a new
person joins the team,
they automatically have
access to the content
that they need to be able
to collaborate with you
and drive the project forward.
The other problem we're
solving with Team Drive
is what do you do
with the content
when someone leaves
the organization?
If you're using a traditional
file store, a NetApp filer,
even a cloud storage
solution from another vendor,
you have to go through
this process of trying
to figure out, when
that person leaves,
I'm going to eliminate
their ID, what
is the disposition
of their content?
Who do I give it to?
Do I give it to their manager?
Do I divide it up
among the team members?
And how do I go
about and make sure
that every single document
is appropriately disposed of
and placed in its proper place?
With Team Drive, you
don't have to worry about
that when someone
leaves the team
or leaves the organization,
the content doesn't
belong to the individual.
The content belongs to the team,
belongs to the organization.
It's a better place
to collaborate.
And it's more effective.
We're also doing a lot in chat.
Chat is a great tool that is
traditionally done one-to-one.
Occasionally, you'll
get a new group chat,
but you're not really
thinking about it
in terms of a team
experience, where
I have a repository
of interactions,
that I'm having with the
team, and have continuity
of the conversations
through time.
So we are bringing to market
a new capability, which
is Hangouts Chat.
And Hangouts Chat
is designed to solve
that problem of being
able to give you
a team, an organizational
view of the conversations
that you have, the informal
conversations you have to be
able to move work forward.
We also are greatly
enhancing our Hangout product
and relabelling that
as Hangouts Meet.
If you've used Hangouts,
you can see what
a great tool it is to
be able to immediately
connect to a number
of people, both in
and outside of the
organization, to be
able to have a video
collaboration experience.
But what you need to make
it an enterprise capability
is you need things like the
ability to record a meeting.
How many times do you do
a team meeting or maybe
an all-hands call, where you're
giving out important content,
but there are people
that are on holiday,
there are people
that are sick, there
are people that have conflicting
meetings and can't make it?
You need to be able to have
the ability to record content.
You also need to make
it seamless for people
to be able to get
into the meeting
regardless of what device
or what location they are
and what the power
of their network is.
So why shouldn't
every single meeting
have a bridge, a
phone bridge, where,
if I'm in a low
bandwidth location,
and it's not possible for
me to get the best out
of my IP network, why shouldn't
I automatically offer you
the ability to dial into the
bridge and just click a button
and be able to be
connected into that?
Why can I connect other
people without having
to type in the conference bridge
number, type in the leader
code, go through all
this sequence of numbers,
realizing that you mistyped the
5th digit of a 15-digit number,
and all the hassle
associated with joining
a meeting that way?
It should be one click.
It should be automatic.
It should be accessible
from mobile, from desktop,
and from any location
that you're in.
So we're doing a
lot in Hangouts Meet
to be able to bring the power
of Hangouts to the enterprise.
You also need to
increase the number
of people that are interacting.
So we're going and increasing
that number every single year
to be able to make it so you
can have large meetings as well
as intimate, small meetings.
So that's we're doing, an
example of some of the things
we're doing around
team collaboration
and getting people together.
What about that fourth place?
What about the integration
of your workplace?
When I'm in email,
and I need to be
able to get to
another application,
I can do it quickly.
What about actually
building applications that
use these capabilities
to be able to provide
new services to
your organization
and to your customers
and partners?
Well, the traditional
development strategy
is great if you're a computer
science software engineer.
So if you're a Python
programmer, a Java programmer,
and you want to go in and
write a complex system
and use all the power that
the cloud has to offer,
that's wonderful.
But what if you're a
power business user?
Where has the market left you
in terms of building a dynamic
and active application built
on top of this infrastructure
and built on
platform-as-a-service to where
I can build a simple
application, as a power user,
deploy that into Google Cloud,
and have it automatically scale
to billions of users, should
I need that capability?
Well, I'd like to
introduce you to a platform
and a development
capability called App Maker.
And I think the best
way to introduce you
to that is to show
you a video of people
that are using it today and the
experience that they've had.
Let's roll the video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- You're on Google, and you're
enjoying the collaboration
products, Mail,
Calendar, Contacts.
However, you also have this
need for a business process
to be automated.
- Our agency, they
don't have the money
to do a full fledged app.
They just need something simple
that makes their life easier.
Right now, we have
the blue form,
because it's a blue
sheet of paper.
- The Wyoming Flexible
Benefits Enrollment Plan.
- You're filling it
out and signing it,
and then they have
to data entry all
that back in, 10,000
people, a lot of blue trees.
- We were able to make
this in App Maker.
- We showed it to
our HR department.
And they were so excited.
- Honestly, at first,
I was very skeptical.
It just seemed too easy.
Like, oh, yeah, I drag and
drop a couple of things.
What do I care?
I'm a real developer.
I don't use these
little gadgets.
But as I got to use the
tool more, I was like, wow,
you know this really can
do some pretty cool stuff.
I was able to develop a
relatively sophisticated app
for login monitoring.
From ideation, all the way
through the final delivered
app, to our administrators, for
them to use, was five weeks.
And that's just unheard of in
any other kind of product life
cycle.
- Why App Maker?
Because not everyone is me.
I really like working deep down
in the code, working low level.
The great thing
about App Maker is
you don't need to have
that deep down knowledge.
People who are
able to make these
really snazzy looking
applications that can
be used by an entire company.
- I never pictured myself
developing anything.
App Maker is an insanely awesome
way to solve a small problem.
- App Maker makes my
job easier, because I
don't need multiple tools.
I can develop it,
directly, on App Maker.
- One word to
describe App Maker?
Simple.
- Quick.
- Flexible.
- Versatile.
- Empowerment.
- One word to
describe App Maker?
Game changer.
[END PLAYBACK]
BILL HIPPENMEYER: So App
Maker creates the development
environment with which you
can build simple applications
that scale to billions
of users on top
of Google infrastructure.
And it sits on top of
a rich set of APIs.
So not only can you
build applications,
but you can also build
applications that integrate
your collaboration environment.
So we've announced the
Spreadsheets API and the Slides
API as examples
of APIs that allow
you to start to
programmatically create
content, programmatically
manipulate slide decks
and do those types of things, so
that you can actually integrate
these types of workflows.
In addition to that,
we've also introduced
the concept of Gmail AddOns.
When you're working in the
context of your email inbox,
that is where I get
a lot of my to-dos.
That is where I'm actually
wanting to do most of my work.
So in the morning, I might
get, for example, a customer
complaint or an
issue or a concern
or some sort of escalation.
In that might be
a trouble ticket.
I don't want to have to leave
the context of my email,
go in and log into the
trouble ticketing system,
look up the reference
to the trouble,
find out what's been done on
that ticket in the last 24
hours, contact the
engineer that's working
on it to get information.
Why can't I simply integrate
that experience, where
I can click on the ticket number
and, through Gmail AddOns,
surface the
application directly,
in the context of
the work I'm doing,
go and look the
information up I need,
grab some of that
information, stick it back
into the email reply,
and reduce the time
it takes to effectively
resolve a customer concern?
If you add those up, over
the course of your year,
you begin to free up, you begin
to work more collaboratively.
You're able to actually leverage
the power of a collaboration
solution that was
built for teams.
So we have a bunch
of technology,
here, in the
collaboration suite.
We think it's differentiated.
And we think it will
help you do what?
We think our collaboration
suite uniquely
helps you achieve the
transformative outcomes you're
doing, based on coming up with
big ideas, which is fostered
by a creative environment, which
is catalyzed by your ability
to engage with others.
So with that, what
I'd like to do
is take you to the final round.
In the US, we would
say, in baseball, we're
heading around third,
and we're going home now.
And to do that, I
would like to bring up
Andre, who is going to talk
a little bit about what we're
doing to maintain
an open environment,
so that you can make sure
that, when you build things
on our platform, they're
going to run in other places,
and that you're going to
work in an open platform.
So Andre?
[APPLAUSE]
[DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDRE HOEKZEMA: Thank you.
Wow, what an audience.
You can't believe how
excited I am about this,
absolutely fantastic.
How are you guys doing?
How is everybody doing?
I was also in the breakout
room, so we have overflow rooms.
I just looked, and we
have almost 1,500 folks
in the venue now.
You can hear the buzz
for the partner room.
To me, this is absolutely,
absolutely exciting.
Four years ago, I
started in Google.
And it went like this.
Hey, Andre, just, here, you have
the Benelux, the Nordics, north
of Europe, and just go
and build the business
for Cloud Platform.
So that's where I started.
And it was absolutely
an amazing journey.
So many, many known
faces in the public.
Working with Philips
was really amazing.
Winning Spotify was
absolutely fantastic.
Coolblue, there's
so many customers.
I'm really privileged
to have seen that.
One of the reasons
that I joined Google
is Google's vision on openness.
And today, I would like to speak
with you especially about that.
And there's three
pieces I would like
to touch here, one, Google's
support for open source
and how Google believes that
it will speed up innovation.
The second is how we are
open to other technologies,
and third,
flexibility in pricing
and how Google believes that
pricing should be flexible
and drive waste down to zero.
Imagine that you
are in a new market.
And you are in a new market,
one way or the other, everybody,
here, right?
The next big thing--
And your competition
has this three year
or multi-year head-start
in front of you.
What are you going to do?
How are you going to compete?
Well, you might think
of Google Cloud, maybe.
Now, this happened to Linux.
And 20 years ago, the internet,
that was the next big thing.
And honest, Linux was not such
a great platform in those days.
Yahoo was really big.
They had their own
operating system.
Solaris was super,
super popular.
And we all know what happened.
Unix became the platform of the
internet, because it's open.
Now, really, because
it's open, because it had
a higher rate of innovation.
Google has a longstanding
history of supporting open
source systems, Linux,
Git, C++, many of those.
That is all anecdotal, right?
So let's look at some numbers.
Over 280,000 commits, from
Google.com accounts, in 1 year,
2016.
So if you do the math,
it's 700 per day.
That's super amazing, right?
15,000 projects that Google
is supporting, over 2,500 long
during projects going on.
And there's another piece,
here, open source is steering
a community of high
collaboration and
of high innovation and
high speeds of innovation.
Let's look at an example.
What started out as Googlers
adding functionality
to the C kernel of Linux,
to just manage resources,
like CPU sets and
other resources,
grew into what we know now
as containers, microservices.
And 12 years later,
now, companies
around to world,
people around the world
are speeding up application
development and DevOps
through containers.
And at Google, we use
that, of course, also.
And containers, in
itself, are great.
Containers also need
to be managed and need
to be orchestrated, right?
So in Google, we have
this humongous robot
that we lovingly call Borg.
And I know, we make the jokes.
Resistance is futile, right?
And Borg, we made a
super bold decision.
Borg, by the way, in
Google is orchestrating
over 2 billion
microservices a day.
So it is quite a
humongous robot.
And we made a bold decision.
What we did is we
open sourced Borg.
And we gave the code
and the management of IP
to the Linux Foundation.
And there Kubernetes was born.
And look what happened.
This is the Kubernetes
project, 4,000 projects,
400 years of effort went
into Kubernetes, 400 years
in the last 3 years.
Now you think, what
does it matter?
Well, at Google, we believe
that freedom matters most.
You write your code
once, and then you
decide, where am
I going to run it,
on-premise, in my private
cloud, maybe, maybe
in multiple clouds, maybe
on the Google Cloud?
So in essence, it means, at
any point, you can leave.
And it also means that, at
any point, you can join.
Now, this is true for
the stuff that you're
orchestrating with Kubernetes.
It also accounts for
Kubernetes instances, itself.
You can run it with us.
You can also use our
managed Kubernetes, right?
And it also is true for--
well, take TensorFlow.
We open sourced that, right?
So you can run it on-premise.
You can run it in the cloud.
But you also can use
our managed services
for machine learning, Cloud ML.
Or you can even go higher
and use our trained data
sets, like we saw beautiful
demos of the Video API and all
that stuff from Lee.
The second part I
would like to touch
is how open we are for
other technologies.
How many of you,
in the audience,
are in financial services
and touching COBOL?
Somewhere, yeah.
So it happens, right?
So anything that you
can run in a container,
now you can point at
with App Engine Flex.
And you can pull it
in and run it inside.
So next to App Engine, how
we support our platforms,
like a Python and Go
and all the seven,
you can now also
add all your code
and put it in and use
App Engine Flex, which
is absolutely awesome.
Another piece I'm proud of
is our continuous support
for Windows.
And not to just be an OK
platform to run Windows code,
no, we really want to be the
best, high performing place
for Windows to be,
so people really
like to bring their code,
bring Visual Studio.
For example, Visual
Studio has an SDK
to seamlessly integrate your
IDE-integrated development
environment into our cloud.
We support all versions of SQL
Surfer, Web Edition, Standard
Edition, and we also announced
support for Enterprise Edition.
We have numerous support
for pre-installed images
for Windows Server,
all those versions.
And also, now and better
Windows support for .Net Core.
So we touched open
source and how
we believe that it's
speeding up our innovation.
We touched being open for other
code and other technologies.
Now, I would like to look
at pricing and flexibility
of pricing.
When I speak with
people about their bill,
their spend on the cloud,
they're usually not that happy.
And that is not because of cost.
Usually that is
because of waste.
That is fixed VMs,
per hour billing,
and then having three-year
leases off those fixed VMs.
And I got told,
somewhere, that cloud
is about flexible resource
and elastic resource
capacity and all that stuff.
So Google believes that
pricing should be flexible,
and that you should
have minimum waste.
And in March, it was, in
2014, Google committed itself,
ourself, to follow Moore's law.
You remember, every year
doubling of compute power.
So where does the margin go?
In the 6%, but the
cloud was going down.
And then we started
driving the price down.
Stick with Moore's law.
And we started innovating.
An example of this innovation
is automatic, sustained, usage
discount.
And honestly, you
cannot screw this up.
Really, you run a VM, and after
the first quarter of the month,
discount starts kicking
in, automatically,
until 30% in the
end of the month.
It's pretty unique.
Another example is how we
have custom machine types.
If you have a 24-core,
60 gigabyte RAM instance,
if you need that,
we believe that you
should be able to run that.
And this reminds me, vividly,
of after all the work
on technology and vision
with Spotify that we did--
I know them very well--
we had commercial negotiations.
And they had clusters,
thousands of nodes for Hadoop,
and they had exotic instances.
And we were trying
to create a business
case, because the strategy
was, we first lift then shift,
and then we peel off
that Hadoop cluster
and get on the
higher level servers,
like Sebastien said
in the beginning.
And we could not close
the business case,
either too much CPU or
cores or too much memory.
And then we did
something special.
Tommy Kircher was there.
He said, hey, let me call
some folks in the dungeon,
and we create a special queue
for them, a special instance
type.
And we did.
And there we could
compare apples to apples.
And now, we have
available, for you,
custom machine types, so
you can compare apples
to apples in your environment.
And if you don't know
what the right size is,
we are monitoring
your infrastructure.
So we will recommend you.
We won't do music
recommendations to you.
But this is more like a
machine-type recommendation.
So you will get it right.
And usually, in the beginning,
through development,
your requirements
from your environment
is very, very different than
in the times of your operations
later on.
So things change.
So if you are planning
your infrastructure
in development phase, you
might go off of the line.
And you'll generate waste.
And then per hour billing, so
we have true per hour billing.
11 minutes is 11 minutes, right?
So you don't have
to put an alarm
clock on the top of the hour
and have to start and stop
your clusters there.
Now, all these elements
are working as a tandem.
Whether it's a sustained
usage discount, that we're
driving our prices down,
or custom machine types,
they all work as a tandem.
And we know, we have seen that
average prices, average bills
are going--
you can be cheaper, like 60%.
And now, nobody is
average here, right?
I would like to close
with, one, open source,
Google believes that
that's the way to speed up
innovation for Google.
Two, we are open, very
open to other technologies,
a great home for
other technologies.
And three, we have flexible
pricing, so that we can drive,
you can drive waste to zero.
And now, I would like
to welcome to stage,
Micha Bruinvels of World Press.
And here's a great example
of bringing code and .Net
to our platform.
And Micha, the floor is yours.
Thank you.
[DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYING]
MICHA BRUINVELS:
Thank you, Andre.
Thank you, Google Next '17.
There is people leaving.
And I just learned,
from the organization
here, that the breakout sessions
will start, as of 11:30,
after this meeting.
So please, all stay here,
so you can learn on all
these wonderful presentations.
So my name is Micha Bruinvels.
I am Director of Contests
at World Press Photo.
And you probably know World
Press Photo for the World Press
Photo of the Year.
And the World Press Photo
is the most important
photojournalistic
contest in the world.
Actually, we say
at these times, we
are the most important
visual journalism contest
in the world.
And I want to explain why.
So I'm going to talk about
exchanging visual information.
And exchanging
visual information
will start with a lovely
video made by Josh Begley.
And this is about 165 years--
listen up-- of front pages
of the "New York Times."
So here, you see
some illustrations,
which took about 50 years.
And then, somewhere after
more than like 100 years--
no.
Somewhere in the beginning
of the 20th century,
they started to have
pictures, as well.
And as of the 1950s, regular
pictures on the front page.
And this, this is the '90s.
Colored pictures
of the front page
of the most important newspaper
in the world, as they say.
So what I actually wanted
to discuss with you
guys is actually to go
back like 20 years ago.
We are an organization.
We were started in 1955, which
is about still photography.
And somewhere here, in
1998, digital came in.
So we accepted digital
photographs in our contest.
It's not even 20 years ago.
And you see what happened.
Blue is digital.
So within five years,
slides were very expensive.
They left.
Prints were out
quite soon, as well,
as they were quite
expensive, as well.
Digital took over.
So what happened
with the digital?
So digital took over completely.
We received more entries.
And people from
all over the world
were able to enter their
entries to World Press Photo.
And pleas be aware, the
figures are not that high,
but that's because World
Press Photo is a contest
for professional photographers.
So it's not for everyone.
So these things happen.
Digital comes in.
Everyone is taking
pictures with this.
But it really took
a while before,
in this professional
context, a picture
taken with a mobile camera or
with a mobile phone did win.
This is a picture
from two years ago.
But also, other mediums
actually were used
creating visual storytelling.
Google Street View won in 2011,
with a story in the World Press
Photo of the Year.
The story is called, "A
Series of Unfortunate Events."
and it was a really,
really great story.
You can see it on our website.
So people were using
different stuff, digitally,
to actually create
visual storytelling.
And we are aware of that
at World Press Photo.
So, as I said before, I am
the Director of Contests.
So in 1955, we started
out with a photo contest.
And since 2011, we have a
digital storytelling contest,
since we are aware,
at our organization,
that visual stories are
produced in a different way
and are consumed
in a different way.
So it's not only
stills, anymore.
Here, we have video.
And we have interactive
stories, visual storytelling,
journalistic visual
storytelling,
using different tools
to actually tell
the story, which needs to
be told, to the public.
This is actually a touchscreen,
which is traveling together,
with our exhibition, to about
100 locations, worldwide,
to actually show
what is happening
in the world of
visual journalism.
Talking about producing and
consuming visual stories,
Snapchat 1.8 million
Snaps per minute.
Whose having Snapchat here?
You're too old.
YouTube, 4.1 million
videos viewed per minute,
which is like 6 billion a day.
The Snapchat, in the end, is
like 2 and 1/2 billion Snaps
transferred per day.
Its massive.
And I need to tell
you, with these things,
talking about who is producing
this visual storytelling,
it's not me who is doing this.
This is my niece.
She is 12.
And this is how she's
communicating with me
after I told her I was
actually coming over.
And she said, well, maybe
this is a friendly picture.
There is a total new
generation growing up
with communicating with visuals.
So we are aware of this
as an organization.
And we want to change.
And this is a picture from 2013.
This is the World Press
Photo of the Year, 2013.
It's made by John Stanmeyer.
And what we found out?
We are learning on this
visual storytelling.
And what we really want is we
want to keep up with the speed.
We want to inform the people.
So actually, what we
did is we are talking
to creators, that they
actually can use the tools
they love and are
very effective.
So we teamed up with Q42, and
we created the Bigger Picture.
And these guys, from Q42,
are longtime .NET experts.
And they helped us with creating
this amazing project, which
I will show you in a minute,
around exploring photos
and exploring context,
using a picture as an entry
point for data journalism.
Since we want to reach out
to this worldwide audience,
we are using Google
Cloud for this.
So I actually want to--
I'm finishing my presentation
with a thing, how
we're going to
explore the context
and expose data journalism
on this picture.
So what we think, at
World Press Photo,
is we think it is really
important to tell the story.
Actually, you know
the saying, a picture
says more than thousand
words, of course.
But a lot of 1s and a lot of 0s
can actually tell you much more
about this picture.
So who are these people?
These people are
African migrants
on the shore in Djibouti City.
They are trying to catch cell
signals, from neighboring
Somalia, since they want to get
in touch with their relatives
before transferring to Red Sea.
So that's these people.
So this is the entry point.
But we want to know,
who are these people?
So we actually want to
explore the mobile owner
or the mobile phone
ownership, which they have,
and which is quite
low for refugees.
But it's really
important to have
a mobile phone for refugees.
What are these barriers to
connectivity for these refugees
when they actually travel
or when they actually
are migrating?
This connectivity,
for these migrants,
is critical, in
the end, since they
need to communicate
with friends and they
need to communicate with others
about where they are actually
going and how they
can go there and how
they can reach better places.
So they use it for
navigation and for directions
to get to the next destination
quicker and, hopefully, safe,
to secure safe routes.
And it's also resilience,
because the migrants, who
are actually like
migrating, who actually
are able to keep in touch
with their family, for them,
they have the best
way, actually,
to succeed in the end.
In the end, this
connectivity empowers.
So it's vital to empower
refugees and to educate
themselves and for earning a
livelihood in these refugee
sites.
So for us, at Word Press
Photo, it is really important
not only to show
this picture but also
to tell the story
behind, which we
want to share with you and
with the public all over.
So thank you, Google Cloud,
for making that possible.
[APPLAUSE]
SEBASTIEN MAROTTE: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
I don't have any
more slides, just
to close this morning
in 10 seconds.
First of all, thank you very
much for all the speakers.
Thank you very much
for the customers.
It's always very inspiring
to have true stories.
I mean the technology is cool.
It is great.
It's powerful.
But at the end of the day, it's
about solving business issues.
And it's really about
hearing from our customers.
So we had great
customer this morning.
If you want to extend
the experience,
the customer experience,
go to YouTube.
I mean go to YouTube,
type Google Next,
and you'll see a lot of
different customer stories
in each and every
single industry.
So this is great.
Because at the end of the
day, it's really about you
bringing your ideas, every day.
Every day, we're hosting
companies, actually.
Everybody's coming
with new ideas.
And they are telling us, we
started the cloud journey,
not necessarily with Google,
a few years, but now,
with everything Google is
doing, the cool technologies,
the machine learning, artificial
intelligence, the data
analytics, and so on, we
clearly do a lot of things
that we couldn't do, actually,
with the first partners we
started the journey.
It's not a one player journey.
It's a multiplayer journey.
And again, we are
really, really here
to get challenged and
share the technology
and start working with
you on the migration.
Having said that, this is
the end of the morning.
We're a little bit
late, so we are
going to start really
sharp, in 10 minutes, all
the breakout sessions.
So thank you very much
and have a great day.
[APPLAUSE]
[POP MUSIC PLAYING] as